this man started the season fourth on
the all-time receiving yards list in NFL
history behind Randy Moss but he's now
fifth behind the fourth place Randy Moss
his Larry Fitzgerald has passed them all
this year Larry now third place in the
all-time receiving yards list Super Bowl
champion four-time Pro Bowler Isaac
Bruce here on the Rich Eisen show good
to see Isaac you know two minutes
you bet so before we get to the Rams and
what you saw yesterday and talking
football and obviously your foundation
you sit down you say it's interesting
that we're talking about the Giancarlo
Stanton straight because you live where
and for louder do okay and then I asked
you if you were Marlins fan and you said
and said no and what your fan of which
team Boston Red Sox
there you go Brockman what's up Isaac
I'm a Red Sox fan for one reason I can
blame it on Ricky Proehl you know he's a
Jersey kid okay any we're always coming
to locker room talking about the Yankees
this and the Yankees dad so you know I
wasn't found that who was the Yankees
rival at that time and it was the Red
Sox and I became a Red Sox fan why would
you do that a Ricky Proehl well I got
tired of hearing about the Yankees in
the locker room so I wanted to be a Red
Sox fan I started learning the players
and uh I was kind of disappointed that
they didn't get in the stanton
sweepstakes well I think that they tried
well I just think Stanton didn't want to
be for whatever reason in the Boston
sweepstakes I don't get that I mean for
summary it's funny that we talk baseball
here because a couple years ago when the
draft was in Chicago hmm we at the NFL
Network were invited to throw out a
first pitch for the Cubs
okay Marshall Faulk because the
Cardinals became his adopted team yeah
refused to throw out a first pitch in a
Cubs uniform no but Curt who's from Iowa
said I'm all in Wow and put on the Cubs
uniform and threw out the first pitch
Wow
I don't think I could have done it
either I mean being in saying those for
14 years right you kind of have to like
the Cardinals at some points no I kind
of felt in favor with them so I don't
want to ruin my my visits to st. Louis I
like it
Isaac Bruce here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you think about what Larry
Fitzgerald is doing right now it's
awesome and I think he's had a great
career um guys
steady always been productive
some this summer at the hall of fame at
Kurt's induction and you know we're
sitting next to each other and I knew he
was close to me as far as receiving
yards or concern and you know I don't
want to trip him up in bright I say do
it in retirement is enough enough
yeah right you know he's had a
tremendous career I'm very pleased with
what he's done what he's done and what
about Antonio Brown the current awesome
stellar wide receiver well in this
league you know you just look at him and
what he can do with the football in his
hands even before he's a great route
runner a guy can take a punch
start and stop with the best of them you
know I love sin and play why do you
think a receivers never won MVP in this
league that's interesting I mean I think
you know maybe one should I mean it if
they separate is two it's amazing how
the light is always shined on the
quarterbacks but you know without a guy
like Antonio or Larry Fitzgerald you
know it's hard for those guys to really
develop so maybe they should just have a
best quarterback of the league that year
in a MVP of the league so and you know
and a receiver could win it well having
worked Isaac Bruce here in the Rich
Eisen show working with Marshall and
Curtis I have for so many years when we
talk about those championship years they
always mention you first they do and
pace comes you know kind of right behind
oh yeah he's my first guy that I'm into
Orlando
I mean without him we we're not effort
we're not we can't have seven step drops
we can't open hose from our shuttle run
I can't get down the field like I did um
and he's the guy that the one guy that I
say we couldn't we just couldn't live
without him well they say the same thing
about you what was it like being there
and then those guys show up what was
that season like for you well Franz ik
from 1994 being here in LA and then you
know making the transition to st. Louis
I took a lot of punches and had some
some individual success but as far as
winning was concerned I didn't I didn't
experience much of it but you're not
fortunate and see all that those guys
come in and watch him develop and turn
into all pros Pro Bowlers and Super Bowl
champions so just having him with me in
a huddle it made me feel even the
about my career in my development at
that time right well when Marshall
showed up though was your first
impression at oh I had you know I'd seen
Marshall I mean I think that he came in
99 we played them in Indy either 95 or
96 mm and you know he was the guy over
there in Indy but he was pretty much the
only guy at that time and you know when
he came in the locker room I was like
okay I think I think I have some help
now mm-hmm and you know it's funny
DiMarco far one of my teammates he says
no you say the defense we have help now
so I was really excited about him coming
to the team and just everything that I
knew that he could do I just I just
didn't realize how well-rounded he was
as a football player I knew it could run
the ball but catching the ball out of
backfield with some though he really
added to it Isaac Bruce here in the Rich
Eisen show what was it like when when
Trent green went down oh man from just
from you know him you know we started to
develop a friendship and just the same
to see your friend down on the ground
writhing in pain and and uh knowing what
he had went through his fart finally
getting a organization or offense that
he could call his own and really never
having that that opportunity to lead
that team the way they I was a
heartbroken for him so and uh you know
hopefully it eased a little bit with
winning the championship for him but you
know I know the guy wanted to play he
was a tough very tough competitor and
then Kirk come strolling in where you
split would you what do you think went
Curt I had no idea
I mean no I was surprised just like
everyone else and you know shook up the
world it really isn't in crowd mean you
can't make this stuff up and obviously
Philly fans are kind of hoping right now
that foals could be there Kurt Warner or
Jeff Hostetler well in a way we'll see
what do you think um I'm Bob honestly I
won't focus on Philly I'm still going to
focus on the Rams in a way you know what
we have before us but it's gonna be it's
gonna be tough I mean I'm sure Falls
gonna get all the rest in practice now
and you know he was there for that very
reason and hopefully once is okay but
you know who knows who knows what you
know what's in store but you but you saw
I mean you saw them in your own two eyes
you were at the game yesterday right
okay
just seeing their offense seeing what
they do in person
do you think that that's a plug-and-play
situation that a veteran quarterback
like foals can just step into and
perform as far as plug-and-play I don't
think so because I think wince is a very
special guy I think he has all the tools
that make up to beat one of the better
quarterbacks in the league I think some
things will have to be adjusted for
Falls
I think they'll run the ball a lot more
than they did but you know wince is a
special special special player Isaac
Bruce here on the Rich Eisen show so
what do you think the Rams can do this
year just this year well it's I think
you can go I'm excited I mean I'm
looking forward to this game this week
versus the Seahawks I mean I think it's
a defining moment for the season and uh
going up there with the challenges of
having to face Russell Wilson again and
that defense that they bring when in
that game I mean I think we're almost
guaranteed a home playoff game and when
you get a home playoff game it's tough
for a team to come in and win on your
home turf so I'm excited about it I
think the creativity and the offense has
really been special this year and hats
off to coach McBay for all that he's
wrong so what what do you think he has
brought what are you seeing
not more in the creativity I think he
has confidence and created creativity
when you have that in offense you can
take a defense and put them on the heals
and get them off their toes so you're
not as predictable with what you're
trying to accomplish on often so he's
brought that into the mix in he's
brought a group of receivers that can
get down the field and take the top off
the defense and gonna open up their
running game well you know what we do in
the national media is we we make
comparisons and we we we throw you do we
throw around words and phrases and that
greatest show on surf got thrown around
yeah do you see any similarities here oh
maybe with the creativity a little bit
but I think we need to just upgrade the
personnel just a little bit more and
maybe we can start making comparisons in
it from that standpoint
okay not right now so where did the
upgrade where did the upgrades that you
see but just probably up front we would
probably get a little bit more
protection better protection up front
and maybe on the perimeter a little bit
okay we'll be ready and you think a home
playoff game would be what does it look
like I mean does it look like a full
Coliseum to you like to the rafters with
people with horns on the sides of their
helmet and on their chests I mean what
do you think that looks like
look for somebody who you were if you
were there in the Anaheim days when it
ended go to st. Louis now it's back here
in Los Angeles where I don't think a lot
of fans could have seen it coming and
then what they had you last year looks
nothing like what they're they're being
asked to buy back into after last year
so well I think it's I think it's a
trust can the Ken Southern California
trust the ramps right now I think that's
one of the biggest biggest issues that
we're dealing with winning at times
cures a lot we could we could bring that
back on but I think um you know when I
see the melonhead's guys like that and
when I saw him in 1994 you know really
let me know that I was in the National
Football League Egan and uh hopefully we
can hopefully you know the place would
be sold out and have a home-field
advantage like we should have all right
let's talk about the Isaac Bruce
foundation do the flight 300 program
provides transportation to college bound
students in need what what's the genesis
of this idea well I grew up in South
Florida Fort Lauderdale and uh it's
funny because you know when college
started for me I was headed out west to
West LA college where I ended up
ultimately going to Santa Monica City
College for a while and I just didn't
have the funds for transportation so uh
you know some kind of way the funds came
along and I purchased the airline ticket
and I got here I spent my two years here
before going to Memphis to play ball
there but you know I got in a position
you know by playing football to offer
these services to other students who are
in need and it's been going strong man
since 2006 and I'm very very pleased
with Isaac Bruce dot-org for more
information on that so Santa Monica
Community College isn't that where Steve
Smith also wound up playing Smith Chad
Johnson there's another one and then I
know another receiver from Fort
Lauderdale Florida very well his name is
Michael Irvin is it really oh yeah oh
yeah st. Thomas Aquinas he'll tell you
about Dillon high school I got to make
sure I say Dillard High School ok very
good
the only reason why I bring this up is
Isaac you are quite unlike many of the
receivers that I have come across also
well your your your an even keeled
individual okay you don't seem to like
to talk about yourself as calculated man
it's calculus is it real I can't talk
about myself but when I was on
fill these you know I know there's a
time and place for everything right and
I was all for my team and I wanted to
make sure that if I had any energy where
I wasn't getting the football enough I
was gonna take it out on another team
and not my team as far as my coaching
quarterback or offensive coordinator at
that time I wanted to extend that energy
to the guy trying to cover me so you
never barked at Kurt you never barked at
Kurt not much no I think we had we had
pretty pretty cool conference or not at
marks either ah maybe early probably 95
96 okay then yeah cuz you're not usually
receivers because they're so far away
from the football like to be heard if
the football doesn't find them well
their position wasn't if I'm being seen
mmm it's a lot better than being hurt so
I trust me I wanted the football a whole
lot more than you know I let on but okay
and I think I got it enough all right
what's gone but then before I let you go
let's talk about let's go ahead okay
because your numbers our Hall of Fame
worthy absolutely you are not in Canton
right now unfortunately I know so what
are you how do you take that the fact
that your and year out it's something
you can't control I understand but how
do you approach that because I've been
around a lot of all-time greats like
Harry Carson who says I don't want to
even know about anymore take me out of
the mix and I see others that are just
waiting around where do you stand
well I guess I'm one of those that
that's waiting around but I'm I don't
think I'm idly waiting around I mean
it's it's it's the culmination of a cap
of my football career it's part of a
dream just like making a Pro Bowl or
being in a Super Bowl and another dream
was catching a game-winning catch and in
a Super Bowl that was one of my dreams
and and ending up in a podium up and you
know you know Canton Ohio
that's one of my dreams so you know my
numbers are what they are and uh you
know what I like to do is just point I
just point to those and you know and
that's that's what pretty much I can do
right now I'm not gonna answer any
question that's posed to me about my
playing career and my numbers and I'll
answer them as honestly as I can
are you one of the best of all time has
he proved absolutely absolutely and I
you know for years I called myself D
best
so yes hmm why do you think some people
need to be convinced to that then you
know what I'm not sure I won't say it's
the market in which I played I think you
know as far as uh intangibles as far as
receivers like is concerned I think I
checked every box
um played hard when I had to play hard
did everything I was asked to do and I
produced on a football field
and if longevity plays a part in net I
played a long time as well yes you did
if you played in today's game what would
your numbers look like oh man might be
the probably the second 20,000 yard
receiving person I was the second 15,000
you're receiving person ever I'd
probably be the second Jerry and Isaac
there you go or Isaac and Jerry very
good Isaac Bruce 80 don't be a stranger
if you're out here here in Los Angeles
come to some Rams games I'll do that
please anytime would love it come by an
FM network also throwing on the set way
with Marshall and Curt
that'd be the grease filter for it
what'd we get Tory we get them all back
together gotta bring be going bring oh
my goodness but not Ricky control right
got to bring Ricky man we we wouldn't
take photos without Ricky Proehl been in
the mix unless he talks about these
right man that's right gosh Isaac Bruce
at Isaac Bruce 80 check out again Isaac
Bruce org be part of the flight 300
program transportation to college bound
students in need and boy do we need more
of that these days
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience